ça c'est du carton avec des trucs sympas
dedans voilà là là là où ça c'est le
joli ça ou que c'est joli où ça me plaît
ça me plaît à temps mais elle est là la
olala ça c'est chouette cpa tant il ya
de choses mais qu'est ce que c'est houle
ou aux 500 comparatif ça ou le petit
machin là et le gros truc
hop hop hop hop hop le truc de malade je
peux littéralement en acheter 10 comme
ça pour un comme ça truc de fond truc de
fou
[Musique]
salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle vidéo
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux et ça
fait hyper plaisir alors aujourd'hui on
va parler de ça ça c'est une optique
cinéma xine et je me suis posé beaucoup
de questions à son sujet et j'ai fait
quelques petites recherches quelques
petit test parce que voilà je me dis que
vous vous posez peut-être la question en
quoi une optique signer c'est mieux ou
moins bien ou à quoi ça sert par rapport
à une optique traditionnelle de des
salaires donc on va regarder ça de plus
près on va voir aussi des petites images
qui ont été filmés avec cette super
optique et puis on va voir lequel est
mieux lequel il vous faut si vous vous
une optique de tester l'air aussi vous
faut une optique cinéma parce que je
suis sûr que vous êtes posé la question
est-ce que c'est utile ou pas et puis il
ya matière à comparer parce que ça c'est
un 50 mm ça c'est un 50 mm lui il ouvre
à 1,8 et lui il ouvre à 1,5 mais on
n'ouvrira qu'à 1 8 par souci d'équité et
enfin celui là coûte 180 euros alors que
cela coûte 1800 euros donc à première
vue sur le papier ses optiques elles
sont censées être à la fois hyper
proches focale ouverture est aussi hyper
différentes que prit la forme tout ça
quoi alors sans plus attendre on va
rentrer dans le vif du sujet et
justement pour vous montrer un petit peu
ce que fait cette grosse bébête je vous
ai tourné quelques images
c'est parti birol
on
taurines
[Musique]
t comme cela
av
[Musique]
c'est ce que
alors on va parler très rapidement de
celui-là histoire d'enfoncer les portes
sont ouvertes c'était un 50 mm qui ouvre
à f 1,8 donc assez grand il est en
plastoc 1 se fait un peu cheap
il a un autofocus et ici on a une petite
bague de focus manuel voilà et en plus
il est petit il est pas cher moi tu es
beau bon et là on est sur complètement
autre chose un cas sa tronche on voit
que c'est pas du tout le même délire on
est toujours sur un 50 mm avec une
ouverture de thé 1,5
on verra pourquoi on dit et et pas f1 un
peu plus loin dans la vidéo et le machin
est quand même bien gros et pèse son
poids alors il faut savoir qu'on est sur
du full manuel là dessus il ya zéro
electronica pas d'autofocus on peut pas
piloter l'ouverture depuis le boîtier
mais par contre on a deux grosses bagues
ici une vague pour que gérer la mise au
point est ici une bague devant gérer
l'ouverture
et autant vous dire que ça ouvre grand
le mach 1 1 tu me vois sur le sony par
contre on a juste une petite bague de
focus qui est en plastoc est un petit
peu cheap il faut dire ce qui est alors
la back de focus ici elle a deux
particularités déjà écrasés ce qui va
permettre de lui greffer un peu ce qu'on
appelle un faux l'eau focus c'est notre
roue crantée avec une molette qui va
permettre de faire la mise au point plus
facilement l'autre truc c'est qu'elle a
une butte et c'est là qu'on peut arriver
en bout de course
à une extrémité de la mise au point et
en bout de course à l'autre extrémité de
la mise au point sa tombe pas dans le
vide le sony lui
alors là ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne
ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne
ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne et ça
s'arrête jamais donc on sait pas si on
est au plus près ou au plus loin de la
mise au point en plus de ça ici on a des
indications sur la distance de focus la
zone est à quelle distance elle se
trouvera ce qui est hyper pratique sur
un set de tournage puisque on va pouvoir
faire un marqueur un endroit là où le
comédien doit se trouver et même sans
regarder le retour juste avec les
indications si on mesure la distance on
pourra savoir si on est ou pas nous
permet d'être encore plus précis et même
si jamais il y avait un déplacement du
personnage on sait qu'à tel moment il
est à telle distance après yves
assure-t-elle marqueur donc on peut même
réglé le mouvement du focus sans
regarder le retour savoir qu on sera
quand même net
si le comédien respecte les marqueurs au
sol enfin si on regarde bien c'est 12
optique ici on à 1,85 ici on à 1,50
on se rend compte qu'elles font
exactement les mêmes dimensions est
exactement le même poids et ça c'est pas
anodin tout simplement parce que sur 1
tournage à bas si on doit changer
d'objectif quand on utilise une
steadycam par exemple vu que le poids
est le même on n'aura pas besoin de
rééquilibrer la steadycam idem pour la
taille si on utilise une mc box c'est
pareil les diamètres sont les mêmes la
langue et la même donc on n'aura rien à
toucher à part l'objectif et même la
bague 31 elle fait le même diamètre donc
pour le follow focus y aura aucun
réglage supplémentaire à faire si on
change d'objectif
et puis pour terminer pourquoi on
utilise la lettre t pour un objectif
signer et la lettre f pour un objectif
classique de dslr c'est tout simplement
parce que si on dit bah f18 sur un
objectif c'est un calcul théorique et
entre deux objectifs de marques
différentes
le f18 sera peut-être pas exactement le
même alors que la valeur t elle c'est
une valeur quasi absolu donc si on veut
vraiment avoir des ouvertures similaire
entre deux objectifs à bala n ya pas de
souci avec le t on est tranquille même
si on a des objectifs deux marques
différentes ou de focales différentes
donc voilà grosso modo les différences
de conception entre ces deux objectifs
qui n'ont pas le même but on est bien
d'accord mais en terme d'image qu'est ce
que ça donne alors de mon point de vue
absolument pas scientifique j'ai
remarqué plusieurs différences déjà le
bloquer à aaa le bouquet quoi le bloquer
le bouquet le bloquer alors je vous
montre l'un après l'autre ici des images
d'abord du 50 mm f/1 8 le sony où j'ai
fait une mise au point manuelle ici avec
des petites loupiotes et à côté la même
chose réalisée avec l'optique signer et
la khl herman il ya une énorme
différence les petits à l'aube lumière
le petit effet ben ok n'a rien à voir
entre l'un et l'autre vraiment si je
trouve ça sublime sur l'optique signer
c'était un régal et l'autre point qui
m'a agréablement surprise c'est que à
très grande ouverture
on avait un flou hyper crémeux hyper
lice au fond qui était vraiment
magnifique et par contre la zone de
netteté et est vraiment hyper net hyper
piqué alors que sur des objectifs
traditionnels généralement avec grande
ouverture et ben on a quand même un
petit peu moins de piqué on a certes ce
flou mais la zone est elle est quand
même un petit peu molle elle s'est pas à
grande ouverture qu'elle va avoir sa
netteté la plus élevée la sur l'optique
signer le flou le net c'est
galia ai jamais mangé de caviar
d'ailleurs c'est ça m'attire pas du tout
de poisson voilà pour les principales
différences en termes d'optique que moi
j'ai pu remarquer alors est-ce qu'il
faut que vous vendiez un rein pour vous
acheter une ou des optiques signer et
bien clairement moi ma réponse mon avis
là dessus c'est que si vous faites pas
du film du court métrage de la fiction
non là et vu l'engin c'est hyper gros
c'est hyper encombrants ça nécessite de
préparer son tournage c'est pas du run
and gun du tout genre tu vas pavlo gay
avec une optique cinéma quoi n'a aucun
sens rimerait à rien non et puis à main
levée ça pèse un âne mort c'est hyper
lourd et oublie de le mettre sur un
rooney sous sur un grain de même pas la
peine d'y penser si tu veux le
stabiliser ça sera une steadicam dans le
meilleur des cas ou alors on aime ou des
choses vraiment gaillard reporter le
truc en plus de ça il ya une différence
d'image on a vu mais franchement ça
reste minime si on regarde sur un
smartphone en a pas forcément voir une
énorme différence entre l'optique des
slr et l'optique cinéma mais ça vient
aussi très probablement du fait que
j'utilise justement l'un des slr et que
sur des caméras comme des raids et si on
shoote en gros il ya fort à parier que
l'optique va donner tout son potentiel
avec des capteurs de grosses caméras et
probablement avec dur aussi donc encore
une fois sur un gros set sur un gros
tournages avec gros matos beaucoup de
trucs gross a totalement sa place et
moyens de sortir des images de tyco et
pour reprendre ce que disait le poète
adelin c'est comme pour un pc ça sert à
rien d'avoir une carte graphique de
tarés si on a deux gigas de ram faut un
équilibre donc en dehors de la partie
optique ce qui coûte cher dans cette
optique cinéma c'est surtout la
conception parce que sur un plateau de
tournage utiliser une optique de des
salaires ça serait ou père galère et une
énorme perte de temps mais d'un autre
côté sur du reportage sur un truc où ça
va vite on a besoin d'être mobile où on
sait pas trop ce qui va se passer parce
que les choses sont pas prévues à
l'avant cela du coup ce serait la xoom
qui serait vraiment pas pratique du tout
c'est le type de petit con donc d
utilisation très différentes
n'empêche que j'ai adoré utiliser
l'optique ci n'est rien que pour le
focus manuel qui moi j'étais pas hyper
fan au départ parce que les bacs de
focus manuel de mes objets sont pas ouf
elle
vraiment on à la précision on a foncé on
en est c'est bonheur du pub pour titre
ou bien trop trop bien et voilà les amis
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura appris des choses
que bah du coup maintenant vous aurez un
petit peu plus en quoi ça consiste
une optique signer j'en profite pour
remercier albert ii est fasciné qui est
partenaire sur cette vidéo et qui m'a
très gentiment prêté les optiques zine
donc voilà vous pouvez voir dans la
description si vous voulez louer par
exemple pour les essayer pourquoi vois
pas ce que les acheter c'est quand même
un petit peu cher ou les louer ça peut
être une solution
et puis comme d'habitude les amis si
cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
mettre le traditionnel coup deux blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe en
dessous de cette vidéo commentée
partager tout ça tout ça
donnez moi votre avis dans les
commentaires et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo il ya
quelqu'un oh non mais ça marche pas ses
lunettes
c'est non c'est j'ai testé ses pannes
non spa où c'est avec fallait que je
fasse la blague parce que voilà avec des
trucs comme ça tu faire le con peut
quand même pas tout